[Musique]
ça va aller
sur le ring ya des règles dehors et à
rien du trou
pl avait elle cogne alors voir des coups
bas mais type comme moi on vit dans le
passé
toi tu as des gens qui ont besoin de toi
maintenant tu as tout à perdre
skyline à perdre est du tout tant que
j'ai pas le choix ça c'est ce que ton
père disait tout le temps
telle est mort dans mes bras donné ce
cas là il est dangereux
tu penses que je peux pas le battre
j'avais peur de pas pouvoir répondre à
ses attentes
tu as encore des choses à prouver à
quelqu'un
c'est
c'est ça
samedi
je veut réécrire l'histoire ne mettre
surtout pas ton père à cette histoire
canada
sans nos peut-être pas l'air pour
l'instant mais c'est plus qu'un simple
combat
[Musique]
adam
ça m'a dit aimer
[Musique]